[Music]
we're going to start off with scott this
hour in fort lauderdale hey scott how
are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i work for a uh for a company that i
get 10 of my salary the ability to
purchase company stock
the stock has been very very fruitful
over the 10 years that i've worked for
the company
the way our stock purchase works is that
we get
to purchase the 10 of our salary twice a
year in a six-month period
at 15
below the lowest point in that six month
period
so the the
sometimes when i get these the stock at
the six months it can be forty fifty
dollars a share better than the market
value at the time
when i read baby steps millionaire in
the money makeover
you talk more about putting your
retirement into mutual funds
i've kind of considered that 10 percent
as being
my part of my retirement
of i take 16 percent out of my total
salary with six percent in a 401k that
that my company matches
and then the other 10
is in company stock
um and the stock has done nothing but
gain in the in the nine years that i've
been there and some big jumps as well
so do i leave that in there and consider
that that
still ten percent of my retirement
or do i switch it like you talk about in
the money make over to mutual funds
well congratulations
sounds like you've hit a home run man
uh it feels kind of good
and so um yeah the your theory has not
been stress tested yet
and uh that'll come along okay first let
me give you a couple observations first
uh number one your company stock
purchase plan is no different than most
of them
they're almost all exactly what you
described 15 below lowest to the
six-month average whatever okay uh and
so it's not like you're getting some
huge discount that other people that
have
the work for a publicly traded company
with stock options don't get it's almost
always exactly what you outline
very very similar if not so uh it's good
but it's not the biggest deal in most
cases if you look at a 52-week high
52-week low on the charts you will see a
move of uh most stocks more than 15
percent up or down
and so that 15 discount can as you said
cause because it's down cause a uh a
great purchase price but also can cause
um you know it can evaporate in about an
eye blink uh but just because the normal
volatility of stock
uh observation number one observation
number two single stocks are more risky
than mutual funds
okay period
no exceptions
because
you're you're violating the
diversification rule you know you got
all your eggs in one basket or at least
that number of eggs are all in that one
basket um and so it's you're taking more
risk even though
you've had the benefit of this company
doing very well it's gone up gone up
gone up i'm happy for you i'm glad it
went up i don't want you to have hard
times uh but uh
but that can that can gloss over the
fact that you're taking risks because
you haven't had a loss
you're not anything that scared you that
woke you up my oh this is risky so what
we tell folks to do our standard rule of
thumb
is uh don't put more than 10 of your net
worth in single stocks
and you currently have more than that
with the formula you're giving me
okay
okay so the example of that always comes
back to my mind was many years ago i was
coaching a lady that had worked for
procter gamble which is a fine company
she had eight hundred thousand dollars
in a 401k it was all in company stock
it went in half the year she retired
so i don't none of my 401k is in i work
for apple is in apple stock oh wonderful
stock yeah
the the stock purchase is a total
separate deal and to be honest with you
dave i i haven't um
i've i'm recently divorced a couple of
years and i was
lucky to get out and be debt free and
you know i've never really read your
books because i never had any i didn't
have any debt but after watching you
with robert morris i uh i
downloaded the first book and then went
to the second book and it really
motivated me to kind of get my
act together yeah well
so
ecclesiastes says
spread your portions to seven yes to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land
and apple is about as
uh
it's about as wonderful a single stock
story as there is on the planet
yeah
it's doubled it's just double oh it's
crazy
we'd have to get rid of some of it they
have more money than egypt
they really do
they actually have more cash than egypt
it's an incredible company
hey you mentioned you read the first two
books and that you originally had kind
of stayed awake because you weren't in
debt but i recommend you pick up baby
step millionaires he did that's what
he's talking about oh perfect well i did
i did i know i read both of the books
i've actually listened to probably
probably three times each well thank you
um so the whole question is do you how
much risk do you want to take and and i
think we can all stand up and cheer and
say apple has done a wonderful job of
all the single stocks out there
it's the one that might be the most
tempting it is an unbelievable story
uh but i still i'm just risk averse
enough to say okay i'm going with a
scripture says spread my portions to
seven yes to eight i don't want my whole
deal on one company
and you don't have your whole deal but
you got a lot of it
and so i'm probably going to be a little
less apple prone if i'm you if i was
ever going to do what you're doing it
would be that company oh my god it's
wonderful okay
so you know if you want to keep doing it
keep doing it i just want you to hear a
lot i want you to feel
that you're you're violating the
diversification principle
and that does nothing but increase risk
inherently in that
one bad iphone launch
one bad lawsuit over a tablet or
whatever i don't know what could happen
i mean i have no idea what can happen
but you know it's
they get cancel cultured i don't know i
don't know how this works but
whatever it is i just don't want it's
not in your control
you're one of a bazillion employees you
don't control this stock
and so i
i i wouldn't be as heavy in it as you
are
but i will acquiesce and say if i was
ever going to be
good lord there you know the the the
financial numb regardless of what you
think of the products or the people or
anything else the financials on that
company are
blistering good
yeah that's a great position to be in
it's crazy yeah it's crazy how much cash
they have
it's mind-blowing but yeah but aside
from that i still
well i mean
i'm sitting here saying how much i'm a
fan boy of their stock
and i don't own a single share
that says i follow the principles i
don't buy single stocks at all and if i
was going to it wouldn't be more than 10
percent of my net worth don't it just
you can do what you want to do but i'm
not doing it thanks for the call